I'm joined Now by Matt Archer who's the
director of commercial space flight at
the UK space agency good to see you this
morning it was all going so well
it was yeah and there are lots of
successes that we take out of at the
launch yesterday we were the first to
launch in Europe and whilst the mission
wasn't as successful as we'd hoped there
are lots of things that we have learned
from it and we know that we can do it
again so lots to look forward to we're
going to do it again
yeah I think we will and it's the
element that will work with Virgin to
understand what went wrong uh this time
around it looks like a technology with
the second stage engine and so in effect
the satellites got into space but just
didn't reach the required orbit to
maintain it so once we know what went
wrong we'll communicate that back out
and we'll learn and we'll go again that
that's the nature of launch we know it's
hard and we know there's always a risk
of failure
um yeah and unfortunately we didn't
quite make it yeah so you think what in
in the next six months the next year
potentially
I think so it will depend on kind of
version orbit and when they can come
back and what's their what's the
appetite to do that quickly and if it's
going to work out what the anomaly is
and what that means for uh fixing it so
um a bit more work to do to put a
timeline on it but looking forward to
um the next launch as soon as it can can
be arranged
and it's pretty depressing for those
people who've invested especially in
those satellites and we're hoping to get
their businesses up and running using
that satellite technology they will have
lost a lot of money but also people will
be losing confidence weren't they in the
UK's ability to compete in this sector
I don't think that's the case I mean so
the satellites will be covered
um by insurance for these kind of events
and so the financial costs kind of won't
won't be uh severe but obviously their
hopes of having Services up and running
uh today to work whether or that's
that's with kind of governments across
the U.S here uh Oman and Commercial
companies in Poland the UK and elsewhere
um so clearly their Ambitions weren't
fulfilled yesterday and that that's
disappointing and we share that you know
this is a project that the UK space
agency has been leading for over five
years
um and whilst we learned a lot obviously
we can't hide the fact that we're
disappointed we didn't kind of achieve
Mission success
yeah I mean when you see what Elon Musk
is doing and Jeff Bezos Cutting Edge
technology in California we're looking
at a 21 year old 747 taking off from a a
rainy Cornwall I mean can we can we even
begin to compete with with that sort of
Technology do you think
yeah they're different offerings so
whether it's blue origin or SpaceX and
and what they're doing in terms of heavy
launch from the US those Services
continue to be available but this is a
different Market this is about getting
to orbit quickly and having a more
responsive access to space and that's
what we're going to deliver here in the
UK
um so we'll see more launches from
Scotland hopefully later this year and
and looking forward to the next one from
Cornwall and that'll see more commercial
and government customers and flying
their payloads in due course so we'll
look forward to that and the technology
in Scotland is is different isn't it
it's a different system up there
yes it is so they'll they'll be more
traditional what you used to see which
is a rocket on a vertical launch pad
um
and again different size Vehicles so
some uh mixture between carrying 200
kilograms or anywhere up to a ton
depending on the systems that are
involved and but again they're largely
going to be taking a small commercial or
government satellites in space and so
that'll be kind of work through over the
coming year and we'll we'll look forward
to doing this again with Cornwall and
having kind of people here on site to do
that again yeah we can hear the the
disappointment in your voice uh Matt um
thank you very much for for coming on
and hopefully we can get you on again
when we have sort of an explanation as
to what went wrong Matt Archer from the
UK yeah